It might sound like a random pairing,
like Marie Curie on Wikileaks,
or Charles Dickens on twerking.
But it isn't.
We know her as a nurse,
the lady with the lamp,
gliding through
blood-soaked army hospitals.
But maybe we should call her
the lady with the bar chart,
because she was
at least as illuminating
in the world of statistics.
So, what would she think of big data?
Florence loved statistics.
She said she found them
"more enlivening than a novel".
And a friend said,
"However exhausted Florence might be,
the sight of long columns of figures
was perfectly reviving to her."
For Florence,
statistics were God's work.
She said,
"To understand God's thoughts
we must study statistics, for these
are the measure of his purpose."
So, although she's
famous now as a nurse,
she actually trained first
as a statistician.
It wasn't until
the beginning of the 1840s -
when she was in her early twenties
and saw hunger and unemployment
all around her -
that she became a nurse.
She'd combined
her nursing and statistics
to become an experienced
hospital manager,
just in time for the Crimean War.
At the time, nurses were seen
as ignorant and lower class.
But Florence changed that.
Florence volunteered to lead
a team of nurses in the war.
Before she arrived, the military
hospitals didn't even bother
to record many of the deaths.
Florence collected data
about everything,
so she could show that changes
in diet and sanitation
had brought the hospital's death rate
down from 42% to just 2%.
It's only when you gather data
methodically that patterns emerge.
Things that were hidden
suddenly become clear.
That might sound obvious now,
but it wasn't back then.
Florence's work made a huge impact
and laid the groundwork
for things we now take for granted -
like being able to compare
hospitals' performance,
or just the fact that
hospitals are clean.
Florence showed what could be
achieved by following the evidence,
instead of gut instinct,
prejudice or tradition.
Another little-known side of Florence
is her talent for infographics.
She turned data into pictures,
making it impossible for MPs
and civil servants to ignore.
So, she would love the
data journalism we have today.
She would love the way big data
makes all this possible.
But she'd hate some of the ways
that data are abused.
She knew that people
can game the system
to make their performance
indicators look better.
So, when you hear of hospitals
fiddling operation waiting times,
think of Florence.
And I think she'd be appalled
at using data to target adverts
and manipulate people
on social media.
This would not be God's work.
Although largely confined to her room
for over half a century,
she worked tirelessly behind the
scenes in coordinating campaigns,
and she always had
a careful media strategy.
So, I think she might like other
aspects of social media.
She'd enjoy the opportunity
to communicate on a grand scale,
with ideas going viral
and so many people being able
to take part in the debate.
Her compassion brought her fame.
And she used that fame ruthlessly,
along with her incredible intellect,
to save lives
on an unprecedented scale.
If she were alive now,
she'd challenge us to do the same.
To look at how we can use
the vast amount of data now available
to save lives.
To make the world a better place.
To shine a little more light
on us all.